problems posed by the computer are
really no different than the problems we
have with other products of technology
it's gonna take a great deal of wisdom
on our part to manage them but if we do
we're going to make a much better world
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
artificial intelligence or AI has the
potential to revolutionize our world the
way we do things and how we live and you
can say that it's already starting to do
that AI will be one of those big tools
that propels us into a new future like
computers and the Internet did decades
ago recently we've seen many examples of
neural nets in particular from speeding
up video game production and making
graphics more realistic to solving
age-old physics problems like the
three-body orbit problem so that's all
well and interesting but we have to
recognize that today in the field of AI
we're building off the shoulders of
giants
so the question must be asked who were
those original Giants
how did AI come to be who were the
people that first dreamed their
computers could think for themselves who
are the pioneers of AI TV
[Music]
what really worries me today is what's
going to happen to us if machines can
think could ask me that question just a
few years ago I'd have said it was very
far-fetched and today I just have to
admit I don't really know I suspect if
you come back and four or five years
I'll say sure they really do think as
soon as computers came into existence
scientists began finatus izing about how
they could revolutionize our world even
in the 1960s they theorized that one day
computers would be able to think for
themselves
there are many pioneers that laid the
foundation of AI even as far back as
Aristotle introducing associationism in
300 BC and this would start our attempt
to understand the human brain but in
this episode we're going to focus more
on the more recent notable contributions
the so called
fathers of AI the first attempt and the
beginning of AI all starts with
psychologist Frank Rosenblatt in 1957 in
that time he developed what was called
perceptron a perceptron was a digital
neural network that was designed to
mimic a few brain neurons Frank's first
task for the network was to classify
images into two categories he scanned in
images of men and woman and he
hypothesized that over time the network
would learn the differences between men
and women or at least see the patterns
that made men look like men and women
like women just a year later the media
caught onto the idea and the hype was
strong in 1958 the New York Times
reported that the perceptron was to be
quote the embryo of an electronic
computer that will be able to walk talk
C riot reproduce itself and be conscious
of its existence
end quote unfortunately for Frank
despite the higher his neural network
system didn't work very well at all this
was because he only used a single layer
of artificial neurons making it
extremely limited in what it could do
and even worse there wasn't much that
could be done about it at the time
computers of that day could only handle
this simple setup
these problems were never solved and by
1969 the computer science community had
abandoned the idea and with that AI was
dead everyone may have given up on the
idea but decades later a keen computer
scientist by the name of Geoffrey Hinton
thought that everyone else was just
plain wrong he theorized that the human
brain was indeed a neural network and
the human brain evidently made for an
incredibly powerful system to him this
was as much proof as he needed
artificial neural networks had to work
somehow maybe they just needed some
tweaking Hinton saw the genius in the
idea that everyone else missed it seems
to me there's no other way the brain
could work it has to work by learning
the strengths of connections and if you
want to make a device do something
intelligent you've got two options you
can program it or it can learn right and
we certainly want programmed so we have
to learn so this had to be the right way
to go so you have relatively simple
processing elements that are very
loosely models of neurons they have
connections coming in each connection
has a weight on it just for
clarification a node is an artificial
neuron and a weight represents the
strength of connections between neurons
that weight can be changed to do
learning and what a neuron does is take
the activities on the connections times
the weights adds them all up and then
decides whether to send an output and if
it gets a big enough sum it sends an
output if the sum is negative it doesn't
send anything and all you have to do is
just wire up a gazillion of those just
figure out how to change the weights and
it'll do anything it's just a question
of how you change the weights Geoffrey
Hinton is the superstar in the AI world
having authored 200 peer review
publications Hinton was instrumental in
the fundamental research that brought
about the AI revolution
after studying psychology Hinton moved
into computer science and pursued his
lifelong quest of muddling the brain
originally from prison in the UK he
moved to the University of Toronto in
Toronto he would go on to develop
multi-layered neural networks
he and his team quickly realized that
the problem with Frank Rosenblatt
single-layer approach was that more
layers were needed in the network to
allow for much greater capabilities and
the computers of the day were now
powerful enough to handle it this
multi-layer approach solved the problem
that Frank Rosenblatt had the neural
networks were much more capable today we
call this multi-layered approach a deep
neural network in 1985 Hinton
co-authored a paper which introduced the
Boltzmann machine Boltzmann machines are
the fundamental building blocks of early
deep neural networks you can think of
them like the Ford Model T of neural
networks without getting into the
details the concept is to have groups or
layers of neurons communicate in such a
way where each artificial neuron learns
a very basic feature from any data for
example each neuron can represent a
pixel in an image that the network is
trying to learn long story short the
result is a program that can make
accurate guesses and predictions about
data as never seen before
soon others began innovations based off
deep neural networks a self-driving car
was built in the late 80s on neural
networks and later in the 90s a man by
the name of Yan Li kun would build a
program which recognized handwritten
digits this program would go on to be
used widely
but Yan Li kun would also go on to be an
AI pioneer in his own right Li kun would
study under Geoffrey Hinton and would
lead the research that made Henson's
theory of backpropagation our reality
back propagation in simple terms is the
process of computers learning from their
mistakes and hence becoming better at a
given task much the same way humans
learned from trial and error however the
idea of AI being used for much more was
short-lived the field was stifled by two
problems one slow and inadequate
competing power and two a lack of data a
burst of investor confidence was
eventually met with disappointment and
the research money began drying up
Geoffrey would become ridiculed and
forced to the sidelines of the computer
science community he was seen as a fool
for his long-standing faith in a failed
idea undeterred by the opinion of his
colleagues Hinton pursued his dream with
an unfazed obsession in 2006 and the
world had finally caught up to him
computer processing speed had grown
significantly since the 90s Moore's law
observed by Intel's co-founder Gordon
Moore stated that the number of
transistors per square inch doubles
about every two years
this meant that computers were growing
and processing power exponentially
that's the first problem solved
meanwhile thanks to the advent of the
Internet some 15 years earlier a wealth
of data had been acquired and this
solved the second problem but but you
know I think about this and what about
this internet thing do you know anything
about that sure what what the hell is
that exactly
well it's it's become a place where
people are publishing information so
everybody can have their own homepage
companies are there the latest
information it's wild what's going on
you can send electronic mail to people
it is the big new thing the ingredients
of a Iowa now they're the computers were
powerful enough and there was enough
data to play with by 2012 the ridicule
Geoffrey Hinton was now 64 years of age
continuing the work wasn't an easy task
Hinton was forced to permanently stand
due to a back injury that would cause a
disc to slip out whenever he sat down
the birth of the modern AI movement can
be traced back to a single date
September 30th 2012 on this day Jeffrey
and his team created the first
artificial deep neural network to be
used on a widely known benchmark image
recognition test called imagenet
Hinton's program was called Alec's net
and when it was unleashed on this state
it had performance like no one had ever
seen Alec's net destroyed the
competition scoring an over seventy five
success rate forty one percent better
than the best previous attempt this one
event showed the world that artificial
neural networks were indeed something
special this sent an earthquake through
the science community a wave of neural
net innovations began and soon the world
took notice after this point everyone
began using neural networks in the image
benchmark challenge and the accuracy of
identifying objects rose from Hinton 75%
to 97% in just seven years for context
97% accuracy is surpassing the human
ability to recognize objects computers
recognizing objects better than humans
has never happened in history soon the
floodgates of research and the general
interest in neural nets would change the
world by the late 2010 image recognition
was commonplace even recognizing disease
and medical imaging images were just the
beginning
soon neural net AI was
video speech science and even games
today we see AI everywhere
Tesla among many companies has created a
sophisticated self-driving AI which is
already sharing the road with humans it
is predicted their self-driving cars
will reduce accidents by up to 90% while
smart traffic lights would reduce travel
time by 26% Netflix and YouTube even
uses AI to learn what shows you watch
and recommend new ones
uber uses machine learning AI to
determine surge pricing your rides
estimated time of arrival and how to
optimize the services to avoid detours
there's also a new interesting
hide-and-seek AI as shown here by the
YouTube channel two minute papers in
this scenario two AI teams battle
against each other one outsmarting the
other as each round of the game
persisted after a given time one of the
teams figured out how to break the
game's physics engine in order to win
this was something that the researchers
never anticipated is the potent
demonstration of a eyes problem-solving
abilities the popular app tik-tok is
completely AI driven leading towards
popularity as we've covered in the
previous video so now a is everywhere
it's in our daily lives even if we're
not aware of it of course there's many
examples of AI being used but perhaps
the most interesting uses will come
after we reach singularity
[Music]
singularity is the concept of a is
surpassing human intelligence after this
point what happens is a bit of an
open-ended question by default computers
would be able to reinvent better
versions of themselves they could
progress fields such as medicine and
science without human direction
alphago zero is a graphic illustration
of the possible rate of this progress in
2016
experts thought that it would take an AI
around 12 years to beat a human at the
ancient game of God a game with
virtually infinite possibilities and a
game that relies on human intuition to
master but the experts were very wrong
the 12-year prediction in reality was
actually zero an AI did in fact beat the
grandmaster of go in that very same 2016
year the next version of the AI alphago
zero learned to play the game from
scratch and beat the previous version a
hundred games to zero in just three days
alphago zero was so good that it was
able to be applied to other things that
it wasn't trained for like lowering the
power usage on Google's data centers the
new breeds of AI could even begin to
invent new tools that humans would never
be able to fathom dr. Richard Sutton of
the University of Alberta says that
singularity is widely estimated to
happen around 2040 by 2030 we should
have the hardware capability to achieve
this allowing for another decade for
people like Sutton to make the code that
achieves singularity it's a rather
unnerving thought that in about a decade
we may have computers that are smarter
than us how many years away do you think
we are from a neural network being able
to do anything that a brain can do so I
don't think it'll happen in the next
five years beyond that it's all a kind
of fog so I'd be very cautious about
making a prediction is there anything
about this that makes you nervous in the
very long run yes I mean obviously
having other super intelligent beings or
more intelligent than us is something to
be nervous about it's not gonna happen
for a long time but it is something to
be nervous about in the long run what
aspect of it makes you nervous well will
they be nice to us also the movies
always portray it
as an individual intelligence I think it
may be that it goes in a different
direction where we sort of developed
jointly with these things so the things
aren't fully autonomous they're
developed to help us they're like
personal assistance and we'll develop
with them and it'll be more of a
symbiosis than a rivalry so seen the
future so where are the pioneers now
currently Geoffrey Hinton divides his
time between his roles as a professor at
the University of Toronto and vice
president at Google Lee Khan is vice
president at Facebook
both of these pioneers had won the 2018
cheering Award for their contribution to
AI named after the father of computer
science Alan Turing who created a
machine to decipher German codes
virtually ending World War two the Alan
Turing prize is considered the Nobel
Prize of computing
artificial intelligence has rapidly
grown in the span of less than two
decades from the fringes of science to
the centerpiece of the world without the
work of these pioneers who refuse to
give up our future may be very different
perhaps we don't fully understand the
potential of AI but nonetheless it
should be obvious that their work has
created a significant point in human
history much like the invention of fire
the wheel electricity computers and the
Internet artificial intelligence will be
one of humanity's greatest tools duties
back conditioned Geoffrey Hinton hasn't
sat down for the last 12 years at 71 we
hope Hinton will keep standing for many
more years to come while AI is helping
many people today we can only hope that
will continually be used for good in the
future so thanks for watching that so
look at the people who created AI and
the history of artificial intelligence
itself next week in the next episode
we'll be taking a look at the very
strange story of the first man to visit
space if you want to know more about the
inventors who influenced our world you
can check out my book new thinking which
is what this video is based off if you
want to see more things on science
technology business and history feel
free to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any new videos ok so before I leave
you here are some interesting examples
of AI outputting data visually cheers
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you